sin derechos humanos no hay justicia
climática Ese es el llamado que están
haciendo decenas de activistas aquí en
una de las protestas en la Cope 27 todos
ellos están vestidos de blanco y con un
pañuelo cubriendo sus bocas en
representación de las voces silenciadas
que han sido precisamente oprimidas al
estar en la cárcel o incluso al perder
su vida por defender el medio ambiente y
también en una representación de las
restricciones para protestar aquí en la
con 27 este todo lo que sí tenemos que
hacer el centro del Blue son este no
podemos decir los nombres de los
gobiernos de los de los países de las
que son los criminales que están que los
que están haciendo contra la gente y Y
si tenemos que pedir permisos tenemos
que decir que es los imágenes que vamos
a usar que son las palabras que vamos a
decir otra de las protestas ocurrió a la
entrada de la zona de negociaciones de
la cop 27 donde activistas climáticos
asiáticos explicaron lo vulnerables que
son sus países a la crisis climática
de los 13 picos más altos del mundo que
superan los 8.000 metros de altura a 8
están en nepal tenemos mucha riqueza en
nuestras montañas pero ahora por el
cambio climático nuestras montañas están
derritiendo Así que estamos exigiendo
justicia climática ahora porque los
ricos están haciendo más ricos y los
pobres lloran
los nuestra demanda es que los países
tienen que pagar por pérdidas y daños no
solo por adaptación y mitigación de
impactos sino también incluyendo
pérdidas y daños los endemets y solo al
final de la 27 se sabrá si este llamado
a reconocer las pérdidas y los daños
será escuchado